some of the pro-trump rioters who
stormed the capitol this month were
closing with
anti-semitic images and messages the
latest sign
of a growing problem in america from
2015 to 2019 anti-semitic incidents
jumped nearly 124 percent that is to a
record high
and some jewish leaders say there is no
coincidence here the growth
of crimes against jews intensified under
president trump
as we prepare to mark international
holocaust remembrance day tomorrow
our jim axelrod shows us examples of the
hate and the personal
toll on those targeted
even among the many disturbing images
the country confronted on january
6th a confederate flag paraded through
the capital for
instance some were more painful than
others
for some americans the future of the
country is at stake here
take audrey glickman a jewish woman from
pittsburgh
who had to look at rioters wearing camp
auschwitz sweatshirts
it must hit you viscerally when you see
camp auschwitz shirts
as part of january 6th of course it does
how could it not glickman is one of the
survivors of the deadliest attack on
jews in american history she was inside
the tree of life synagogue in pittsburgh
that horrific october day in 2018
when a gunman stormed in and slaughtered
11 of her fellow worshipers do you ever
wish
that what would come out of the tree of
life
shooting isn't more hate
but a collective wake up hey we got a
problem
absolutely that has been my wish from
the very beginning
that people would understand but
we've seen more shootings since then
more killing
people are not understanding how do we
make them understand
for starters understand the numbers
according to the anti-defamation league
acts of anti-semitism started spiking in
2016
after a nearly 15-year drop the most
recent statistics show the highest
number of anti-semitic incidents
in its recorded history more than 2100
acts of assault
vandalism and harassment against jews
if you are alarmed looking at this data
it's because it's undeniable
something is going on and we're all
concerned about it
of course it got worse jonathan
greenblatt is the anti-defamation league
ceo
he notes the spike pairs with former
president trump's rise to power
and says that's no coincidence some of
this i think is because we've had
you know a leader at the top who's been
bullying from his
different platforms relentlessly every
day if you buy the concept
that those who forget history are
condemned or relived
how much of your brain is given over
to the possibility what we saw the 6th
of january
was just the beginning but what i would
say to you is that what just happened
is really if you will the end of the
beginning
i think we're now moving into a
dangerous new phase and it's going to
require government
and business and civil society to work
hand in hand to lock arms to push back
on the surge of prejudice
that history is front and center for
annie polland
president of the tenement museum in new
york often
in the united states we study the
holocaust which is
incredibly important and that needs to
be studied too but
just as important in this country is to
look at how anti-semitism has manifested
itself
let me see your stickers in the last few
months alone it's manifested itself in
the form of swastikas on street corners
in california and virginia
a vandalized anne frank memorial and a
menorah
shot with a pellet gun during hanukkah
when we see anti-semitism
rear its head in the form of the symbols
in the form of sweatshirts that say camp
auschwitz
you know that's a that's a problem for
jews in america
but more deeply it's a problem for all
americans yet despite the spike
in anti-semitism audrey glickman says
that awareness
not only breeds alarm but also brings
the hate out of the shadows
and in the bright light there is hope
there is always hope
there is always the possibility of going
forward and doing better
even if it's small steps it's a big
country and it's a big world and there
are a lot of us and
the people who hate are not the majority
yet we can do this
the bite administration is set to
restore funding to address domestic
extremism that the trump administration
had cut
as for president joe biden he plans to
appoint leadership at the department of
justice that will prioritize
the prosecution of hate craps jim
axelrod thank you jim some
important reporting there it is a
problem for america
you can hear more of jim's conversation
with the anti-defamation league's
jonathan greenblatt on today's cbs this
morning podcast